this is a message to all the good men
out there in the world
some of you are asleep
and some of you have lost your way
and it is time to wake up
Edmund Burke said the only thing
necessary for the Triumph of evil is for
good men to do nothing
we are in the time of our lives where we
need good strong men to rise up we need
strong men as great leaders to stand up
for what is right and to be an example
to other men to show Valor honor
chivalry discipline responsibility
honesty loyalty and good leadership
these are the things that used to make a
man a real man the things that turn a
boy into a man of character and we
needed more than ever because evil is
taking over the world and we need to
overcome evil with good
the Bible says in Romans 12 21 do not be
overcome by evil but overcome evil with
good
we live in a world where the definition
of what it means to be good and what it
means to be evil that's questioned
people don't know what the truth is
anymore the definition of what it means
to be a man
is also questioned men are told that
they should be more feminine that they
should be less masculine that they
should not be leaders of their homes and
that there should be no difference
between a woman and a man
a man and a woman are not the same we
are equal yes but our roles are
different
there are things that women can do that
we men cannot do and that's okay
and there are things that we men can do
that women cannot do and that's okay
that is what makes us unique different
and we should use those differences to
help each other Albert Einstein said
women always worry about the things that
men forget
but men always worry about the things
women remember
in my marriage I always forget things or
not always but a lot so I forget my keys
or I forget my jacket and my wife she's
the one who remembers oh you put it here
you put it here so she helps me in my
weakness and also I help her in her
weakness so when she's not strong enough
to carry something that's heavy I'm
there to help her so we are not equal in
those kind of things we are equal in
value
right the husband is not more important
than the wife or the wife more important
than the husband we are equal but our
roles are different and we should use
our strengths to help each other in
those areas where the other partner is
weak
now this gets very serious here learning
to be a good man a good leader starts at
home
with you fathers out there are you
teaching your son with love in truth to
be a good man according to show me the
father ninety percent of all homeless
and runaway children are from fatherless
homes 85 percent of all children showing
behavioral disorders come from
fatherless homes
63 of Youth suicides come from
fatherless homes 71 of pregnant
teenagers come from fatherless homes 85
percent of Youth sitting in prison come
from fatherless homes and children from
fatherless homes are four times more
likely to live in poverty ten times more
likely to use drugs and 14 times more
likely to commit rape
now those are just the numbers of
fatherless homes what about those homes
who have fathers but they are terrible
abusive
breaking their kids down so they grow up
and they don't have confidence in
themselves they don't know what it means
to be good men good women you have the
responsibility to be a good father take
a hard look at yourself in the mirror
and take this responsibility seriously
it is your responsibility
to teach your sons
to become good men the Bible says in
Proverbs 22 verse 6 train up a child in
the way he should go even when he is old
he will not depart from it
real men do not run away from their
responsibilities
especially your responsibility when it
comes to your own family of being a good
son of being a good husband and of being
a good father
if you run away
and you don't take care of your
responsibility the family structure will
fail
why is that so bad
because when we look at a society with
all these families who failed we have a
society that fails
Russell Nelson accurately said
throughout the world the family is
increasingly under attack
if families fail many of our political
economic and social systems will also
fail
now we say that the family is under
attack by whom
by evil itself working behind the scenes
through big corporations governments
even though celebrities that you follow
in social media and even in school
systems today look at what they're
teaching your children good is now
called evil and evil is now called good
they want to change
what they think is normal which is not
normal at all
look at the men today focused only on
money quick fixes they're lazy want to
have things that they don't work for
they lie easily to get what they want
they care more about their outer
appearance instead of improving their
inner self they just want to get in the
pants of girls seeing women as objects
or even other men instead of respecting
people they are selfish lovers of self
proud arrogant abusive disobedient to
parents ungrateful and they have no
self-discipline or self-control over
their emotions
you can't say anything to them because
it's all emotional oh you hurt my
feelings they care more about emotions
than they care about the truth your
emotions should follow the truth
this is disgusting what people are doing
today what men have become
and if you are one of these men
you have no right to complain about the
world
because you are part of the problem
it is time for good men to stand up for
what they believe in
it is time for good leaders to stand up
and lead with boldness strength and
determination but to do so in love truth
humbleness and wisdom
we need Men of Honor Integrity men who
can be trusted looked up to respected
men who lead others to become better
unselfish courageous strong and bold men
of Faith who can be a light to those who
live in this Dark World men who believe
in God and doing the right thing even
when no one is looking
this is a type of man as being attacked
today
by evil through things like even cancel
culture and of course fake media
listen very carefully
the Bible says in proverbs 10 verse 11
the mouth of the righteous is a Fountain
of Life but the mouth of the wicked
conceals violence and Proverbs 12 5 says
the thoughts of the righteous are just
the councils of the wicked are deceitful
evil is not going to come and say hey
I'm evil look at me follow me no
is going to come and deceive people to
try and show them hey this is something
good but behind it they're so hook
and that's exactly what they're doing
with everything that's going on in the
world brainwashing people
we need good men good leaders to stand
up not tomorrow not next week today
if we do not stand up for our values
morals good values and good morals for
what we believe in then how can we live
with ourselves
we can't
light cannot be hidden under a basket
you put it on the stand so it lights the
whole house so that everybody can live
in truth and here's the thing
the only thing that can stop you
is fear
but the Bible says God has not given us
a spirit of fear but of power and love
and self-control a lot of men today
should get a backbone
courage get courage make the decision to
change for the better
do not waste your life
but use it for good to make a difference
to bring value in other people's lives
to change the world you might be a
diamond in the rough someone who can be
a great leader but you might be too
focused on your own selfish Ambitions to
make money to get the best house and the
best car
okay
and once you have that
what then
you die and it is all for nothing
you can receive the whole world left for
the world in your sinful flesh and at
the end you die and lose your soul
because when you die you will stand in
front of God and how will he judge you
Jesus said I tell you on the day of
judgment people will give account for
every careless word they speak
you see being a good man a good leader
is not just about what you do but it's
about what you say so what you say and
what you do those things together what
example
is that to other people
Marshall Goldsmith said those who lead
by example and demonstrate a passion for
what they do make it much easier for
their followers to do the same
if you want to become a good leader then
it all starts with you
you need to change yourself
you need to be the change you want to
see in the world and then you'll be a
great example to other people and if you
want a role model someone to look up to
the perfect example of the perfect man
that's Jesus Christ when he walked on
this Earth
he was a good man a good leader
and he led by serving others Wayne Mack
said a leader is first and foremost a
servant
he's concern is not for himself his
concern is not to give orders to boss
other people around to have his own way
his concern is to meet the needs of
others
it is time to wake up to rise up
and to make a change in this world
good men stop sleeping Wake Up Stand Up
use the time that you've been given
effectively for the right things at the
right time
open up your eyes to the spiritual world
and look at it through the spirit see
the evil for what it is and then
overcome evil with good
and no one can do it for you you have
your own race in this earth to run
and on that road there is a clock every
day you wake up is a day closer to your
death
use the time that you have if
effectively
overcome evil with good
always remember life is short
so don't waste yours
just guys